[Musique]
salut aujourd'hui on continue notre
série sur les criminels l'épisode 3 et
on va s'intéresser au tuerie de masse
est-ce qu'il existe un profil type pour
ce genre de tuerie que dit la science à
propos de ses tueurs fous et surtout
est-ce qu'on peut parler de contagion
pour ce type de phénomène on va voir
ensemble ce qui se passe dans la tête de
cet tueurs et on va notamment s'appuyer
sur le cas de la sanglante tuerie de
Columbine dans le Colorado comme vous le
voyez c'est le troisième épisode sur la
thématique un peu des psychopathes et
des sociopathes et on voulait faire un
focus sur ce cas particulier que sont
les tueurs de masse
dans cette vidéo on va beaucoup se baser
sur des faits qui se sont déroulés aux
États-Unis puisque c'est malheureusement
bien plus répandu qu'en France en 2019
les États-Unis ils ont connu 41 turines
de masse c'est un nombre record depuis
les années 70 déjà qu'est ce qu'on
appelle une Turing de masse à partir de
quel moment on peut utiliser ce terme et
bien c'est quand l'acte a engendré au
minimum 4 morts en excluant l’auteur des
faits puisque parfois après avoir tué
des personnes il retourne l'arme contre
la question qu'on peut se poser c'est
qui sont ces personnes qui arrivent à
commettre de tels atrocités et quand on
regarde les vidéos de surveillance c'est
comme s'il vivait sur une autre planète
et ça ça soulève la question d'une
enquête effectivement on constate une
partie d'entre eux partage des points
communs la violence familiale la
désillusion une volonté d'abandon de la
vie d'une manière générale plusieurs
études ont démontré que sur sans
diffusillades 60% étaient liés à la
violence conjugale ou familiale le reste
n'a pas d'explication directe mais en
réalité pour les chercheurs il s'agit
d'un problème de frustration en gros il
y aurait une différence débarqué entre
la situation de l'individu et ses
attentes ou ses rêves est-ce qu'il y a
d'autres facteurs possibles oui comme
pour les autres vidéos je me demande si
le sexe a une incidence le fait qu'on
soit masculin ou féminin d'après le site
d'investigation mother Johns qui a
recensé de nombreuses tueries de masques
96,5 % des tueurs sont de sexe masculin
donc là pour le coup on a quand même un
pourcentage assez révélateur les
sociologues Rachel kalich et Michael
Kimmel explique que le passage à l'acte
serait pour les tueurs la seule manière
de se réapproprier leur identité
masculine est-ce que les troubles
mentaux rentrent en ligne de compte et
bien contrairement à ce qu'on pourrait
penser les troubles mentaux ne sont pas
un facteur prédominant michaelstone
psychiatre à l'université de Columbia
explique que seulement 22% des tueurs de
masse qu'il a recensé souffrait de
maladies mentales puisqu'il n'y a pas
majoritairement de troubles mentaux chez
ses tueurs peut-être ont-ils des
difficultés sociales et c'est ici que se
révèle les facteurs les plus
remarquables selon ce même psychiatre
43% des tueurs ont été victimes de
harcèlement 61% ont souffert d'addiction
à des substances et 70% écrit comme
étant des personnes très solitaires à ce
stade sans en être certain à 100% on
peut se dire que quand même il y a un
dénominateur commun derrière tout ça
mais pour tuer autant de personnes il
faut être en colère si on est en colère
peut-être qu'il y a un désir de
vengeance derrière si on en conclut que
tous ces tueurs ont connu des faits de
violence où se sont sentis isolés dans
leur vie sociale on peut se poser
légitimement la question du désir de
vengeance et ce qui est une volonté de
se faire remarquer de rendre l'appareil
d'une façon très virulente Adam Langford
c'est aussi posé la question c'est un
professeur de criminologie à
l'Université d'Alabama il explique que
des gens qui se sentent négligés
préfèrent parfois attirer une attention
négative plutôt qu'aucune attention
caricaturalement c'est un peu comme le
phénomène de bad buzz c'est à dire je
préfère qu'on parle de moi en mal plutôt
qu'on parle pas du tout de moi et selon
le psychiatre Jeff et Swanson le tueur
se perçoit comme un marginal il existe
des scénarios culturels qui lui donnent
un modèle l'idée que si vous sortez et
tuer des gens vous allez devenir un anti
héros célèbre qui fera la une de tous
les journaux donc là on parle de voûte
partout et c'est un peu ce qui s'est
passé pour Dylan Klebold l'auteur de la
tuerie de Columbine qui a proclamé avec
fierté que le réalisateur de films se
battront pour raconter cette histoire
c'est dramatique mais il a vraiment dit
ça justement parlons un petit peu plus
de cette célèbre tuerie appuyons-nous
sur ce cas pour comprendre la mécanique
de saturer je vous en avez peut-être
déjà entendu parler et peut-être que
vous connaissez très bien cette histoire
quoi qu'il en soit vous ne savez
peut-être pas tout sur le profil
psychologique de cette erreur pour
remettre un petit peu dans le contexte
le lycée de Columbine est une école
située dans le Colorado qui a fait
l'objet d'une fusillade de masse très
très meurtrière le 20 avril 1999
Eric Harris et Dylan clében deux élèves
de slicé s'introduisent dans leur école
il est 11h10 et les deux hommes sont
armés 11h19 les premiers coups de feu
retentissent patin Nielson professeur
d'art plastique parvient à prévenir la
police par téléphone 11h24 un policier
se rend sur les lieux et un échange de
tirs se fait entre lui et les deux
hommes 11h29 Eric et Dylan pénètre dans
la bibliothèque et là c'est le début
d'un drame une cinquantaine d'étudiants
sont cachés sous les tables il est deux
hommes tirent dans tous les sens 11h42
il quitte la bibliothèque déambule dans
les couloirs et les salles de classe en
terrorisant les élèves cachés midi il
retourne dans la bibliothèque et
finissent par se suicider au total ce
sont 13 personnes qui ont perdu la vie
et 24 autres qui ont été blessés mais
quel était le profil psychologique de
ces deux tireurs comment on en arrive là
il y a une caractéristique commune à ces
deux personnes le harcèlement tous deux
se sentaient rejetés et étaient harcelés
d'une manière ou d'une autre et c'est là
que vous allez me dire oui mais les
milliers d'élèves qui subissent du
harcèlement scolaire font pas tous
forcément se mettre à assassiner leurs
profs et leur classe entière alors oui
évidemment et heureusement et c'est pour
ça qu'il est aussi difficile d'établir
un profil psychologique type de tueur on
l'a vu ça dépend de beaucoup de facteurs
le sexe de la personne victime d'abus ou
non facteur génétique ou non pays
puisqu'il est plus facile de se procurer
une arme dans certains pays que d'autres
etc et pour le chercheur Pablo madridza
il y a quatre grandes causes qui peuvent
expliquer les turines de masse bien que
certains ne passeront jamais à l'acte
même si possèdent ces quatre critères on
a tout d'abord le vécu d'intimidation
pour les troubles mentaux le sentiment
d'isolement et le sentiment d'injustice
et justement il y avait plusieurs de ces
facteurs dans les cas des risques de
Dilemme les psychologues les psychiatent
le FBI qui auront un travail sur la
ferme ont conclu que Eric Harris était
un psychopathe tandis que Dylan Klebold
était un dépressif le psychologue Peter
Langman va plus loin en affirmant que
erikari s'était un psychopathe rempli
d'orage égoïste et manquant de sens
moral et que Dylan clébard était
psychotique souffrait de paranoïa et
présenter une pensée déstructurée les
psychologues s'accordent toutefois à
dire que tous les deux n'étaient pas
atteints de schizophrénie ou de troubles
bipolaires il n'avait pas entendu de
voix par exemple qui qui leur aurait
commandé leurs actes ces actes étaient
bien le fruit d'une rage personnel et
intérieure ces deux jeunes hommes qui se
sont rencontrés à l'université de
Columbine sont rapidement devenus très
proches et ont formé un duo infernal en
raison de leur faille respective ça a
été un petit peu comme deux aimants qui
s'attirent un cocktail explosif qui a
provoqué ce passage à l'acte par contre
il faut quand même que je vous précise
que ce contexte dans la théorie de
Columbine est très particulier puisque
il y a deux tueurs mais dans la majorité
des ce sont des tueurs solitaires s'il
ne s’était pas rencontrés les deux
est-ce que l'un ou l'autre serait quand
même passé à l'acte évidemment il y aura
pas de réponse à cette question le
mystère planera pour toujours mais c'est
intéressant de se la poser ce qui est
intéressant également c'est que les
journaux intimes de ces deux hommes ont
été retrouvés et là on a des éléments
explicites concernant leur personnalité
leur mal-être tous les deux avaient une
réelle fascination pour les armes à feu
tous les deux étaient fans du jeu Doom
je suis pas sûr que c'est un lien si
évident et tous les deux étaient fans de
la violence en général mais ce qu'on a
retrouvé le plus dans les deux journaux
intimes alors qu'il s'était pas
concertés pour les écrire c'était des
intentions suicidaires et beaucoup de
plaintes qui parlaient des gens qui les
harcelé eux deux des amis de Eric et
Dylan racontent qu'ils étaient
effectivement l'objet de harcèlement
constant en permanence il raconte que
par exemple un jour une tasse de matière
fécale leur a été jetée dessus que des
élèves les encercler en leur vidant des
sachets entiers de ketchup sur eux que
les moqueries étaient récurrentes et que
le harcèlement se présentait sous
différentes formes toute la journée on
est d'accord ça n'excuse pas ce qu'ils
ont fait le professeur Aubret emelman
c'est tout particulièrement penché sur
le profil de Eric en se basant sur les
écrits de son journal intime il explique
que Eric a développé un narcissisme
malveillant avec des caractéristiques
antisociales et borderline Eric n'avait
pas d'empathie pour les autres au
carreau mort il était très rancunier il
avait une soif insoutenable de contrôle
il fallait qu'ils puissent contrôler
toute son environnement lors de la
tuerie eric a notamment crié tous les
sportifs levez-vous nous allons prendre
les gars aux casquettes blanches les
sportifs de l'école secondaire de
Columbine n'avait pour coutume de porter
des casquettes blanches donc on voit
bien que c'était une des cibles pour
Eric et probablement cette cible était
du fait de son harcèlement c'était
sûrement les gars qui le harcelaient le
plus un rapport officiel a conclu que
Eric est influencé par le sadisme tandis
que Dylan était plutôt influencé par la
vengeance on tient à une sorte de
portrait robot du tueur de masse qui
correspond fortement aux dires des
chercheurs dont je parlais tout à
l'heure un homme rejeté isolé avec un
désir de vengeance à ce jour les
autorités du Colorado ont dans l'idée de
démolir le lycée de Columbine parce le
lieu serait devenu une espèce de source
d'inspiration pour des Turcs potentiels
et à l'approche du 20e anniversaire du
drame une jeune femme complètement
obsédée par cette histoire à semer la
terreur dans le Colorado avec des armes
ça donne des idées ça donne rien de bon
pour le moment cela bibliothèque ou sans
survenu la majorité des TC a été démoli
et transformé en mémorial mais la vidéo
ne s'arrête pas là dans les journaux
intimes des deux jeunes hommes des
éléments troublants ont été retrouvés
ils ont notamment évoqué d'autres
fusillades comme l'attentat de klaoma
City et même la guerre du Vietnam pour
eux il s'agissait de les surpasser de
faire mieux d'aller encore plus loin
d'où ma question au début de cette vidéo
est-ce qu'on peut parler d'un effet de
contagion et dans un sens où nombre de
tueurs s'informent sur le mode
opératoire des autres criminels avant
eux comme beaucoup d'autres
comportements humains un phénomène de
copie sociale peut alors avoir lieu des
chercheurs des universités d'Arizona et
lillinois ont confirmé ce fait en se
basant sur une simulation mathématique
sur une base de 232 sur une masse les
chercheurs indiquent que la probabilité
d'une prochaine tuerie et grandissante
dans les 13 jours qui ensuite une il
semblerait que les tueries inspirent
d'autres potentiels tueurs qui seraient
peut-être pas passer à l'acte s'il y
avait pas eu la durée précédente chérie
Tower c'est une professeur de
mathématiques à l'université d'Arizona
affirme que la médiatisation peut jouer
un rôle auprès des invitus à risque donc
il faudrait peut-être juste informer
mais pas trop faire de grands sujets
vous savez des chaînes où ça tourne en
boucle après durant des heures et des
jours faudrait pas en faire un phénomène
aussi puissant peut-être il faut
d'ailleurs savoir que suite à la durée
de Columbine 354 menaces de tuerie ont
été comptées dans les 50 jours qui ont
suivi alors quand en normal une ou deux
menaces par an maximum étaient dénombré
ce qui est fou c'est que la plupart de
ces menaces ont eu lieu dans les 10
jours qui ont suivi donc on voit la bien
qu'il y a un vrai phénomène d'imitation
probablement auprès de personnes qui
sont déjà fragilisées le criminologue
Franz Robert explique que la tuerie de
Columbine a joué un rôle prépondérant en
tant que modèle en Allemagne par exemple
un élève a blessé 22 personnes dans son
ancien école à en évoquant
Erik Harris disant de lui qui s'agissait
d'un dieu plus récemment et c'est en
France cette fois-ci un homme de 19 ans
a été mis en examen alors qu'il
projetait de faire une tuerie de masse
dans son ancien lycée et dans une
mosquée et il avait fixé son passage à
l'acte le 20 avril 2022 le même jour de
l'année auquel la tuerie de Columbine a
eu lieu est-ce qu'il s'agit d'une
coïncidence pas du tout puisque dans son
journal intime cette personne avait
justement évoqué la fusillade de
Columbine avec je cite le souhait de
vouloir faire pire que Columbine il se
disait aussi harceler et abusé en bref
il est très difficile d'établir un
portrait robot du tueur de masse on sait
que c'est une combinaison complexe entre
des facteurs environnementaux familiaux
et individuels même si bien sûr on
retrouve souvent des caractéristiques
communes comme le rejet social ou le
sexe de la personne j'espère que cette
vidéo vous a plu et que vous appréciez
la suite de cette série c'est pas
quelque chose de joyeux mais ça n'en
reste pas moins intéressant vous me
dites dans les commentaires si vous
voulez qu'on continue cette série si oui
sur quelle thématique personnellement je
trouve qu'il est important de à tous les
sujets et de toujours chercher à
comprendre la relation qui a entre la
cause et la conséquence donc qui vient
de quoi qui provoque quoi j'en profite
pour vous faire découvrir la prochaine
couverture en exclusivité du prochain
curieuse voilà c'est ici vous avez le
lien dans la description si vous
connaissez pas c'est mon magazine au
format papier ou au format numérique il
arrive tous les mois chez vous les frais
de port sont inclus dans le prix de
l'abonnement si vous souhaitez vous
abonner il y a un lien dans la
description comme ça vous pourrez déjà
aussi découvrir un petit peu tout ce qui
est déjà paru ce qu'on a écrit et vous
faire un avis merci d'avoir regardé la
vidéo pensez à la liker à la partager si
vous avez trouvé ça intéressant à vous
abonner si c'est pas le cas à activer la
cloche ça fait beaucoup de choses mais
comme ça vous êtes sûr de voir passer
les prochaines vidéos ici je vous mets
les deux premiers épisodes si vous les
aviez pas vu si vous me connaissez pas
je m'appelle toujours Fabian olicard
prenez soin de vous à très bientôt Ciao